I speak to you today at the same hour as my father did exactly 75 years ago.
His message then was a salute to the men and women at home and abroad...
...who had sacrificed so much in pursuit of what he rightly called a "great deliverance."
The war had been a total war. It had affected everyone, and no one was immune from its impact.
Whether it be the men and women called up to serve; families separated from each other;...
...or people asked to take up new roles and skills to support the war effort,...
...all had a part to play.
At the start, the outlook seemed bleak, the end distant, the outcome uncertain.
But we kept faith that the cause was right...
...and this belief, as my father noted in his broadcast, carried us through.
Never give up, never despair. That was the message of VE Day.
Today, it may seem hard that we cannot mark this special anniversary as we would wish.
Instead, we remember from our homes and our doorsteps.
But our streets are not empty; they are filled with the love and the care that we have for each other.
And when I look at our country today,...
...and see what we are willing to do to protect and support one another,...
I say with pride...
...that we are still a nation those brave soldiers, sailors and airmen would recognize and admire.
I send my warmest good wishes to you all.